[Music]
all right this
should be let me mute everything else
that we don't need all right
this should be up let's see got a good
light
streaming
all right i forget how much of a delay
there is
all right everything looks good
cardinal you hear in chat let me know
all right so i gotta click over
here here we go all right look i got my
shirt
i was able to meet up with uh quincy a
couple weeks ago we chatted had an
awesome chat so want to say thank you to
him and he got me a
shirt and i told him i would wear it
every stream but i realized
i just have this zoomed in so apparently
i'm gonna have to work with my webcam
but hey
all right everybody uh we have all these
awesome contributors uh uh i spend
uh all my time as volunteers so
if you guys could go down below and grab
something a shirt a cup a hat
should ask for a hat i should have
thought about that maybe
maybe i'll go on and buy a hat but uh
just go down and support free code camp
uh quincy and bo and his group are doing
an amazing job all these everything here
is uh 100 free
and they are doing a great job and uh
i want to help out as much as i can
because like i said with the chat with
quincy uh really kind of see what he's
thinking and got going and i just i
think the organization is great
so there we go all right
so what in the world am i talking about
about
chicken nuggets and itter tools
is uh is everything let's see is chat
back up and running i know i restarted
everything let's see
all right good cardinal is everything
good
i should probably have discord open so i
could see you just one on one that might
be an idea for next week
all right okay cool so chicken nuggets
so actually i stole
this uh project from uh someplace else
but the idea of the chicken nuggets is
you have
and it's from a very well-known
organization
they have combination of chicken nuggets
of 6
9 and 20. and the challenge is the
problem is
uh for you to write a
function to take it started with
started at least 50 and what we'll find
out is we'll
use the skills that we have um
uh you guys can just put in chat and uh
we have
uh some awesome moderators and they'll
make sure that what
um uh
uh what needs to get through gets
through um
so all right but i digress so the
challenge was
take i want 50 chicken nuggets
what combinations of our six nine and 20
to get 50 and then really even
sophisticated what happens if i wanted
53 chicken nuggets
how would we go about that so let's just
get into it and then what we'll find out
is we'll
we'll write a little bit more and we'll
see how in the world
can we get basically every combination
and then we're going to look at a
very awesome module uh itter tools all
right so i got about an hour so let's
just jump into it
so if you guys are new here i'm sam from
python basics
uh supporting free code camp so make
sure you're going to get something today
and uh we're going through all the
videos that i've already done so you can
see down in the
uh description below um
anything that we're we've done here and
you didn't quite get it
there is a video for it alright
so let's get at it nuggets
i get all right
pass so let's just kind of think about
this first
so we have oh i didn't even check
can we see this i need to shrink that
didn't think about that
boom so we have our combination we have
six
we have nine and we have 20.
so how in the world are we going to do
this we need to think about this
like a did i keep the picture of the
odometer
i did or the flipping clock
so this is the way i want you to think
about this and how we're going to solve
it and how we're going to lay it out
and then how we need to design it let me
make sure you can see this
okay so we have 6 we have 9
and 20. so we need to revolve
through and as we get back to a certain
number of combinations of one
then we need to flip it over i was
thinking about an odometer
but then i was hard to find a flippy
old-timey odometer than i thought about
a bunch of things but i'm a lot older
than most of you guys
so um found this image of a clock
so this is what we're going to do we
gonna we're going to start with six
so we go one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten then we're
going to flip over to nine
and then we're gonna and then we have to
reset then we're gonna come through
and go one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten flip over
and then another one so what does that
sound like
the tools that we already have does
anybody
have any i have way too many
um
all right let's see
no this is not our first
video this is
cardinal you might be able to help me
this is our 9th or
10th but you can also click down in the
description
the playlist has every single playlist
that
of all these videos bo has done an
awesome job of consolidating them
but all right so basically this is how i
want you to think about this
this is nested for loops so we're just
gonna pick an arbitrary 10
and we're just going to hack through
this at first
we're going to go 10 6 combinations
then flip over to 9. then we're going to
do 10 more 6 combinations
flip over to 9. then once we get to 10 9
combinations
we're going to flip over to 20. then as
we're doing this
we're going to check and see
if this total are total because y
is going to be our total number of
chicken nuggets
let's just do total let's change that i
had y
in my in my experiment so i probably
need to change that to
two
there we go
and then where's my other y i got a
couple y's in here
because that will be confusing to you it
makes perfect sense to me
all right total and one more total
so then we need to think about our
challenge with our loop and then how to
get in and out of it
so we're gonna i'm gonna just kind of
walk you through
so we're going to be taking all of these
combinations and a lot of them aren't
going to work
a lot of them as we go through these at
one point we're going to have one
two three four so four
if we have four combinations of six
that's 24
and then two more uh 18s
or two more nine which is 18. so 6 times
4 is 24 and then 9 times 2 is 18
18 and 24 that may not be any
combination we want
so we're gonna let our program sort
through all of these for loops
and go from there so all right
let's get our let's get our layout
so then we're going to need to collect
these and see
and it's good good practice and
experience
so basically our first general idea
is we want to know how many combinations
of these different chicken nugget
packages to get 50 chicken nuggets
that's our starting point
all right so we need to get some
variables going
so we got 10 or excuse me uh 20
9 and 6. so 20
9 and 6. let me flip over here to chat
make sure i'm not missing anything
global great question
all right this means that
a variable inside a function
can be moved in and out
and um because
a variable by by default
is a local variable if it's inside a
a function and it typically cannot be
pulled out so i wanted to do global
so that when we are going and we want to
test and look at our dictionary
that has all these combinations we can
just pull it out so that's what i'm
doing right now
but yes that is absolutely true cardinal
thank thank you very much it is the 10th
all right so cardinal is uh
our mod um cardinal's been around
a while uh been very helpful and has
moved up
and is actually an admin
on uh the python basics discord
and also a moderator on
this free code camp stream so just want
to say
thank you as always to cardinal
okay so we need to get a for loop going
so we have three different
combination values
so we need to have three for loops
yes that is the absolute idea so we need
to then go through
and set up a function so each time
through this iteration
that we need to then so um
that math uh formula right there
is absolutely it except we're just gonna
use these
because that variable's gonna just go
through
so that is exactly it so let's just get
at it
and then we're gonna look at some pretty
cool stuff but this is just
a great just a great thinking
problem how in the world can i go
through
and move through all of these
combinations to test it
so for i in range
10 and this this was just my first
hack my first attempt at checking this
there are
tons of better ways to do this i haven't
looked at this since i first solved it
and i've wanted to wait years to go back
because
i know there's better ways but i have
not wanted to test it
until um we got together and to do this
to see what actually comes out of it
because there are much better ways all
right
so this is going to be our
20 nugget combination so that's
our that's our outer that's like our
um on our ring going around
just like this so this we're going to
cycle through our sixes
all the time we're gonna cycle through
our
nine loop every 10
times through and then we're going to
cycle through our 20s
every 100 times through does that make
sense
every time through so 10 10 go arounds
then move up to here
so basically this is our singles our
tens and our 100s place
all right okay so now
then we go and we're just nesting all of
these
for range 10 should get chat open
all right that's just our test
right now we're going to test for 50 to
kind of wrap our head around it because
there is a threshold where below that a
combination of these will not work
but in the original instructions for
this problem
50 and up works for every single one and
then i'm gonna
we're actually gonna use our skills that
we have
about um try and accept to see how low
it can go
to go from there so all right here is
our that's our
um nine combination
and then now we're gonna do our hijk
in range but yeah our first mental
starting point is 50 so we know it'll
work
all right
but yeah guys this is not for spamming
cardinal has instructions to just uh
remove and then boot because we are here
um uh
for learning purposes light like i said
um all this is free um and we have best
intentions in mind
and we just wanna have a good clean
supportive community
all right thanks thanks cardinal all
right
so now we need to test
and see how in the world we need to do
this
so this is a little junky because again
the i wanted to show you exactly my
first attempt at this
all right so and that
function that mathematical function
actually has to keep saying function
but if we look over here i think
somebody already threw it up
but it's going to be
k so if we go i think i changed it
around so it's
in in order so
this is our 20 this is our nine
this is our six so we're going to stay
consistent
so i
times t
plus j
times
n plus k
times
let's see k times s
so this is our loop right here here's
our variable
every time through i i times 20
j times n k times s
all right so now we want to test this
and i actually have this here and i was
going back and i i peaked a little bit
and i was like i need to
exactly know so we're throwing in
into into the dictionary because i
remember this was very similar to my
first way that i solved
our primes oh my goodness if you haven't
seen that attempt
at how to find a prime number on my
first example
it was horrid yes tt is the total number
of chicken nuggets that we
are t ttl that we are wanting
so we're going to input so our first
attempt is going to be
50. so we are going to input nuggets 50
and we want to get out the number of
each combination how many 20s how many
nines
how many sixes because i think
what i originally did in this go round
was i let it go through every single
combination and then i sought out
and then you could actually then see
because you're going to see
well the editor i don't want anybody to
be over
overloaded all this is is the python
editor because i know that it can be
challenging
uh for new people to find the right
editor and feel like they're overwhelmed
i just use shell when i'm doing when
every single one of my tutorials it's
the
it's the python editor script and
and then um the shell because that's
sufficient
thank you cardinal
yeah cook if we're not we're not gonna
spam here
all right okay
so now here's my
thank you cardinal all right
because in my experience um there can be
some uh
issues for um where programs
are and files are laid out for new
people and pride charm can be very
overwhelming
and frustrating so if you have
experience with pycharm
you're very easily able to put this into
your
pycharm program so that that's that
all right so then
i'm making so right here is i have my
key value
i'm putting these in and i want you then
to be able to go back and look at all
the combinations that are here so far
so here's my key and then i'm going to
be assigning the value
and it's going to be my k where did i
change this
nope let's stay consistent i
j k so what am i doing here
so each time through it's going to get
the total
it's then going to write this key to
this dictionary
and we're going to see the values
again i know this doesn't really have a
purpose right now but
i have no problem
showing you the absolute really ugly
stuff
that i did when i was first learning to
program so now what
in the world am i doing here
so then we got to come out here
break actually
did i yep then if
ttl equals total
then break then
no all right for those of you who don't
know
you can de-indent a region
boom
yeah that works
let's do that and then yeah here we go
and
if total equals
tote anybody see my mistake i missed
a equal sign so let's go through this
real slow because i think we have
probably quite a few new people
yes we are going to print um but
all right so break only moves you out
one for loop
so as we come through we need to kick
out
each single time
so all right
so here we go one two three one two
three
all right so now i need to now we're
gonna
now we're gonna get some printing
and this is yep all right
one two three
y
then
x y
and
two sorry i just realized off the top of
my head that i rearranged these and i
didn't change it
six piece
then
you know i don't i know you guys are i
want you bored out of your
mind so this is one
this is zero and this
is nine and this is 20. all right so i
just realized i changed that last part
didn't catch that
so now when this reaches
when this is reached our total
our tote of our combinations of each of
these
matches this stop stop stop
and then print out the combinations and
i need to
then come here and one two three
close this out so why am i doing this
like this because i want this on multi
lines
so when i use my three quotation marks
this is it's a multi-line um
control of a print statement so this is
my
f string formatting and i want this to
come
go in to my that needs to be
sorry ttl when this is here
then out of my dictionary grab my key
and that needs to be ttl as well
so you could change this where once this
total
happens again this i wanted to show you
how
ugly my first attempt at this was sorry
let's just run it
uh oh actually we need to pass in
uh nuggets
50.
okay so the way that i had this come out
is i
said i want the total so
there's my total that i pass in then i
want to see
how many combinations is six so that's
what
this placement is because i'm writing
this to my dictionary
i need five six piece and i need zero
nine piece and i need one t one one t
one twenty piece
now all right so
let's pass in let's pass in
a test to see so right now i told you 50
works
about 49.
oh okay so i get 220 piece one nine
piece
okay that's pretty pretty uh
uh what 40 hang on let me see if i
remember
all right uh 47
how do we get that how do we get 47 so
three
three by s so three sixes a nine and a
twenty piece
all right so now we're just kind of
hitting and missing
so now let's let's change this up
so we know
we have skills to do some things like
this
so right now if i go and i change
let's just see combo
so now i just want to test a bunch of
range of numbers
for i in range
let's go 0 through 100.
now we know 0 is going to throw an error
so let's just
let's just try this nuggets
i and
humble append
i then accept
print i
no results
and i think i just changed that up on
you guys so now
bam that was fast
so let's see where does this so of
course
zero zero zero so we can't find one
two three four five but we can find six
then we can't get seven eight nine so as
you can see we can go through
and i'll just show you but from if
memory serves 44
literally from 44
chicken nuggets to the end of time
you can find any number of combinations
so as you can see right here
no results is the first as the last one
at 43.
you could even find 40 was it 39 blew me
away
so yeah you can have 39 and of course
36 is uh really simple it's just 6x6
but this was an absolutely awesome
example
well yeah i wish i could speak uh
other foreign languages my my
younger son is doing spanish and my
older son
he's he's been talking about trying to
learn russian
so all right now let's get on to some
cool
very cool stuff we got 30 minutes
and if if if
this gets buried um you can always just
click over to my channel from the
description down below
and check this video out and i think i
am probably going to redo it but hey
just to remind you guys it's been 30
minutes since i've done this make sure
you're going to buy
a shirt or a hat i should i think i'm
going to buy a hat so i can have it on
to buy a hat and sorry about the the dot
on my face i'd
forget it the time of year is changing i
usually don't film
this time of day so i need to hang
something in front of
hope it's not too disturbing for
everybody other than my normal face
being being being on the screen but all
right uh let's see
okay uh
itter tools let's just get after it so
what what is ittertools
let's get down to the bottom um
import iter tools
enter iter tools
so here is a bunch of
methods from itter tools so let's run
help
on iter tools
692 lines let's bring this over just a
touch
so we're going to go through some of
them
uh i think the one you'll like the most
we're going to skip
accumulate because i wasn't sure what
our next
topic was going to be but we are going
to do operators because
but we need to learn about operators
before we can do accumulate that is a
perfect example
but um uh count we're going to do
what we're going to do today uh if we do
have if we have time we're going to look
at chain
we're going to look at a chain from
iterable
combination count and then we're going
to use the tools that we have to go over
a suggested video that i had that i was
able to
tie these all together but if you guys
are new here
um i thought
that this would work because there was a
lot of chatter about
how to practice for loops and all of
these things
make sure you check out my video from
yesterday about
filling up your toolbox so that's why
i'm probably most excited about this
video or this stream today about itter
tools
because once you learn learn these
things
uh if you you you when you have a
problem
you want to make sure that you have a
variety of tools instead of just walking
around with
one tool that you have and you keep
trying to just use that hammer
because everything will start to look
like a nail that's an old
old-timey carpenter saying
okay so yeah here we go
uh chain um count
yeah i i think count is probably one of
the coolest and then we'll just
head on so let's let's comment
all this out there's our stuff from two
weeks ago
all right so from
like i said we're gonna do chain first
so from itter tools
import chain so chain is a very cool one
so does anybody not know what i just
typed
from intertools import chain so
durr on editor tools
so now so here's my module iter tools
then here is mine let's see if i can do
my alphabet
um there's chain so now
once i run so if i wanted to run help on
if i wanted to see the documentation for
chain
in my shell environment right here
i have to do it or tools dot
chain now with this keyword from
i jump into itter tools and i pull out
just chain so now when i run this
i come over here so here's the
documentation for
itertools.change so the chain method
in inside editor tools chain class
inside module itertools now that i've
done this
i can just run help on chain
so i've grabbed chain pulled this out
and now this
is a function method
sorry boom
just like this all right so now what
let's see what in the world this does
so x equals abc
y equals d e f
e f z equals
g h i had to cheat on my alphabet so for
i
in chain
x y z
and print i so chain will literally
link all these together
boom and then make a new
iterable and as we know we can iterate
through an iterable
and this just uh kick them
straight out to wherever you'd like them
to go
now now let's say we had these
in a
list so we got
x y and z
throw this in a list now let's look at
um
yeah so now i have chain here right i
have chain
and i run dir on chain so i'm one level
inside of chain now
from iterable this is one of the
rare ones where a method then has a a
method
all right is everybody following that
so
yep very nice
very very nice somebody already caught
the um
uh args
and that means it can take
an endless amount we use this on
our uh oh i can't remember but that is a
very good
very good checks very good catch
so now now that we throw this in
now we go now i throw it in an iterable
a list so for
i in chain
dot from
iterable i could have just hit but i
don't want to do that so then i pass it
this and i go print i i get the same
result
but if you already have a
list and you don't need to go through
you can just slap that in there
all right now we're getting close
to some of my favorite ones all right
i don't need that anymore let's just
and again if you are new what i have
been doing and i've been
i'd like to say that i'm very successful
so i've been adding
so uh down over on my page what you'll
see is um i know the more recent ones
the older ones are not but the more
current ones um
no it's not better than pycharm it's
just
you don't need to do anything to it to
run a
because actually pycharm then pulls in
the interpreter
and runs it off here this is the bare
bones i am here for
new new new people to remove any
concerns any fear any i'm
i'm here to tear down the um
the the any any any any fear
or any um anything that can scare new
people away because a new person
learning programming
the likelihood of them running into a
challenge
of any type slows them down from
learning i want to show them how they
can start solving and writing code
with the littlest of of challenges you
don't have to go and get other software
i'm here to teach them how to learn
how to learn to program how to get
success under their belt
then they can go off and solve other
problems and learn about what
interpreter
they want or what editor they want to
use
okay all right so
sorry about that little tangent i just
saw
but no i'm not going to get into a
discussion about what editor to use
did it's that i'm here to show you guys
um
uh how to program all right
uh combinations combinations
from iter tools
import combinations
mnations as
co b so now now what now what did i do
so now i got now i just told you what
this was
now i changed it and added this all
right so i've thrown up another
keyword called as that's called alias
aliasing so i'm bringing this in but
before we had chain brought in chain
right here
well now i don't have to type like if i
did this and do
it as c chain would be called c so now
combinations
is called com okay so now when i do
c o and b it has been
aliased referred to nicknamed
c-o-m-b all right so cool that's what
that is
so now letters
a b c d e f g
all right okay
that caused a all-out war saying that
i'm not going to talk about editors
i'll see a few people left
all right
okay all right
so oh i got sidetracked i know where i
was talking about
github so i know on my very on my
current
videos that get published it has a link
to my github
i have a running file of the free code
camp
dot p y and then i also throw in the
notes of the day
from the shell so you can see everything
that we typed
live or ran it will be dated
today's date always the current date and
then the free code camp
dot p y it might be just fcc
dot p y it that is the running um
extension and i add to it and i edit it
every time after class
uh right now what we're doing is we're
running through
um
we're running through the module itter
tools we just did we got done earlier
uh this morning going through a how to
write a function
to capture um uh chicken nugget
combinations
if i wanted 50 chicken nuggets how many
combinations of each packaging quantity
would i need so there we go that's that
and then now we're
on our third example or excuse me our
third method
for um intertools we're looking at
combination right now
and what we're going to do with
combination is i want to see
well i don't want to misspeak too fast
all right x
i want to run combinations
of letters
and if i spell right it's even my
variable
3 so all right so what am i doing
should probably run help on
commv okay
very good documentation here all right
so it takes in two
two arguments an iterable
and the quantity
of the combinations from that interval
so if i were to pass
range three excuse me range
four so that's zero one two three
right then i want
all i want all the combinations
of three of those all right
and there we go so now
to kind of that is can be a little
much to see from in my experience so
that's why
our example is going to be for uh
letters so i want here's my
here's my iterable it's seven letters
and i want all the combinations of
it's going to be this this this so let's
just let's just do it
so why and i'm going to print these out
we're going to do list comprehension
join
i for i and x
boom so this is making then another
iterable of all the and i want to then
join them and that's supposed to be dot
uh now let's run this and see what in
the world we get
let's bring this in so we can see it
and this is the example that i love to
do
there are 35 combinations so i want you
to look at this
so abc
boom then a b
d a b
e a b so we're here we're here right
here
a b f then a b g
then it moves over ac and it's a c
d then a c e so all right does everybody
see that
so i have all i have this
string i have an i have a string i have
an interval
and this iterable is a string and i want
three of those with all the combinations
and python has this wonderful algorithm
that goes through
and goes okay you just want three of
these and you want
all the combinations of an
assortment of these three which happens
to be
strings so it's that's the first one and
then it moves over
and does the first two then it comes
through
and it skips over to c and d so then
a c a and c say stay
stay stationary then d e f and g
as we can see we got here's here's a
great example
so i want to show you so it's a c
and g so a c
and g then it moves over to a
d a d and e
so boom boom
boom so as it's going through because if
it were to
do any combination any other pattern
than this it would have duplicates
right so this shows you how to logically
think about
an assortment just like our combination
and our wheel of flipping around like an
odometer
or a clock so all right it is 47 minutes
after
so it's time to make sure we're going
down
and buying a shirt a hat a cup i think
there's a mouse pad
something make sure we're supporting uh
free code camp
it is they're doing an absolutely
awesome job
all right so let's see
all right okay we got 13 minutes let's
see if we can fly through this because
you guys
i remember when i saw this one so now
we're gonna do count
who remembers next who remembers next
yes you can watch this video after beau
has this set up
awesome thank thank you cardinal
all right so from
editor tools import
count all right what in the world does
count do
it's so cool
oh yeah let's just look at it count it
or tools count help
count it's so neat
oh wait a second
what is this okay
first first value zero
it's equivalent start step so
oh look at this
we know a double underscore next
means this means that when we create an
object
a count object we can use next on it
and here is the awesome thing about
count every other time we have a
generator object and we use
we use next it is exhausted right
it has a stopping point so
a generator object has limitations count
does not it literally just starts
you will never run out so all right
let's just let's just look at this
so count equals one
so now i put in i call
i call x right
so i still call x right
x count stays one until i call
next on it call next on x
one but then it's done something now
it's two
they work together so if i want
something to be counted and i don't want
to have to keep up with it
and i don't and i know i need to use
next on it
but i don't know where that ending is
going to be like a list
of customers a list of
accounts i don't need it to end i don't
want to
have to go back and go oh my goodness
kind of like what we did
i doubt i doubt any of you remember but
in 2000
uh we had an issue where all of the
birthdays nobody thought we'd ever ever
run into
um 2000 so all of the birthdays were
basically built into 1900s
so we had to go back and change
everything
so we set a limitation so now everything
has been removed
so this next is just like that
so now when i call let's call x again x
stays there until i call next on it
and now x x is three
and it just it just sits there and these
work
hand in hand so all right i think i got
i got nine minutes let's see
and then i gotta go i gotta i gotta get
moving i got
i got a lot i got a lot to do today so i
hate that i hate that we only get an
hour today but still
and also probably gonna we're probably
gonna be going to two weeks
um
okay chicken nugget problem
many okay christian let's see
for the chicken nugget problem uh we'll
have to
cardinal make a note of that question
right there from christian
and see and help me remember to look at
it because we got nine minutes i want to
try to do this
different ascending so i was going
through all the notes
whenever i have so this
was an awesome question that came up
and it worked perfect for
inter tools if i remember yeah
so how in the world could you do a
number pyramid because here's a perfect
i love
number shapes especially uh
pyramids triangles uh diamonds
it's an outstanding exercise for for
loop understanding
okay so how
how in the world could we do this using
the tools that we have
very simply it's all right start
equals oh we got to bring in our
awesome toolkit
all right so from
iter tools import
count so then count
1 by 2. so what what did
did anybody notice what count does
help help
count all right
okay
so start or count it takes a start
and step step is the iteration so we
want to go every two
so we don't have to handle we don't have
to handle the spaces we're going to use
the tools that we just
added another tool to our toolbox then
our num
is going to be count we're going to
start at 1
count 1. all right so
4 i in range
four then print
this is one two three okay that looks
right
times 3 minus i
i forgot how convoluted this was
excuse me and
all right so what does n do anybody
remember
all right i know i'm flying through a
lot so what does
inside the print oh that's not right and
that's ugly
that is absolutely not right this needs
another parenthesis
there we go and we check that yep i got
it
so what is my end equals uh empty string
who wants to comment that puts it on the
same line absolutely
more correct it suppresses the ret the
new line
because the default for print
right here shoot let me see yeah
i think i got this sized right
the default argument for end is a new
line
every time python runs unless we change
it
it's going to return to a new line
didn't pass anything new line moved down
so when i do this
i get two lines so
actually i've never done this so this is
why i love
if i then suppress it i'm back to
getting
one line so this automatically gives me
an empty line
so when i pass it a empty line i get two
because the default
is so i pass an empty line new line
and i suppress a new line i'm back to
one line so cool
this is why i like doing these same
examples over and over and over again
because it makes me think it makes me
better so you guys
the question is look this is super
important if you guys have a question
ask it
even if you kinda or if it's something
you just learned ask that same question
because somebody else doesn't know that
that information all right
how do do for j
in range
next this is where it gets cool next
start
boom boom print
oops
print next
num then
end and i need a space
and i think there's one mistake in here
i think it there i left it on purpose
all right so we need to go
this is it right here assume
awesome so let's see what this does why
why does this just run and taper off
because i'm running through and i need
to make sure that i have a starting
point
so there we go so all right
well i think that is a great stopping
point and but look
you guys are asking a ton of good
questions
and i just want to again we got another
15 minutes went by
just make sure we're supporting free
code camp but look i just can't tell you
guys this
enough just keep programming
just keep writing just keep
asking questions there are a ton
of ways and a ton of resources free code
camp is a perfect example
my channel fills a gap of the micro
video if you can't find
something i promise you it it has a
simple
small video on my channel every single
one of these topics
has its own video the chicken nugget
example it's its own video you can go
through
some people uh love these long formats
other folks want these small things when
they're working on a project and they
can't remember or don't know
and it's fine but don't ever delete
anything if i can tell you that
i wish i would have heard that forever
ago when i was starting to learn to
program
don't ever delete anything comment it
out
save it archive it however and also
make notes in the side when i'm off here
i go okay uh it's
it's the starting
point because look you're gonna come
back a year later
five months later two months later and
go what in the world was i doing what
did that mean
make notes over here because look when
you get skilled up and you're passing
this on to somebody else
you know what that variable means
somebody else is not going to
that's very clear if i were to have that
as x
nobody knows what does x do
start is very clear it's the starting
point and then you have a comment over
here
make sure you're making notes for
yourself don't ever delete
anything reach out ask questions
be part of a group look this is already
hard enough
don't be on an island don't do this by
yourself
and always always always make sure
you're filling up your toolbox
with new skills new problems
and then here's the thing that i love
after you've solved a problem you're
like i'm so big and bad
i've done this i've done look
this is garbage but it worked
okay get it to work get some success
under your belt i used to love hearing
well you need to go get some confidence
how do you go get confidence
you go get successes i want you to go
get successes i want you to go
learn how to do a problem solve the
problem
go back do it a month later solve it
again you know what you're going to
write better code
i remember if you guys haven't seen the
ones that i showed you about
prime numbers go go look at the live
stream that i did on free code camp
i showed you the iteration of how i did
it the first one that i did
was disgusting but it worked
but it was what the skills that i had at
the time
i used what i had at the time and then
then i got more skills then i filled up
my toolbox and i went from there
so all right that's my little rant for
the day but two weeks i don't think i'll
be able to be back
in town for next tuesday uh does not
look that way right now so i don't want
to
i don't want to set it up and cancel it
because we might be going to
one every other week so let's plan on
that but
please please please guys make sure
you're going and checking out
my channel down below seeing if there's
anything there that
i can help you with uh join our discord
buy some free code camp merch make sure
you're helping them out
make sure you're subscribed and join
their awesome organization
i love the opportunity to be able to do
this
it really truly is is an honor so i
appreciate beau and quincy
they are doing some phenomenal work all
right guys i'm heading out today
uh thanks as always make sure you're
liking subscribing sharing
um and helping out somebody look if you
want to get to be a
better programmer go go show somebody
something you've learned
it'll it'll cement your understanding
sorry guys
thank you as always and uh i will see
you
in two weeks bye everybody